il avait quitté rouane le 10 février
souriant les experts de l'om s et leurs
homologues chinois avaient rendu les
premières conclusions sur les origines
du coc vie 19 presque deux mois plus
tard le rapport a été rendu public un
rapport qui suscite de nombreuses
réactions les interrogations sont
toujours nombreuses
l'hypothèse d'une fuite du coronavirus
d'un laboratoire chinois
il y est notamment décrite comme
extrêmement improbable une déclaration
qui est loin de satisfaire la demande
mondiale sur l'origine de la pandémie
nous sommes d'accord et nous disons
depuis longtemps comme je viens de le
dire qu'il manque des données des
informations cruciales
il n'y a pas eu d'accès cela manque de
transparence d'après notre évaluation à
ce jour qu'il soit à la hauteur de la
situation et de l'impact que cette
pandémie a eu sur la population mondiale
les états unis et 13 pays alliés comme
le royaume uni et israël ou encore le
japon réclame aujourd'hui plus de
transparence et de coopération de la
part du gouvernement chinois
des investigations supplémentaires
doivent être poursuivis par des experts
indépendants souhait de l'union
européenne et du patron de l'om est oui
même de son côté pékin rejette toute
controverse et le terme de complaisance
la chine n'acceptera jamais les
accusations sans fondements et les
calomnies gratuite de la partie
américaine sur la question de l'épidémie
une douzaine d'experts mandatés en chine
du 14 janvier au 9 février dernier entre
quarantaine de 14 jours et plusieurs
visites encadrées et médiatisé
comme celle de l'institut de virologie
de roanne et d'un marché local désigné
comme le premier foyer de l'épidémie
quinze mois après l'apparition des
premiers cas de kovy 19 l'hypothèse
d'une transmission du virus à l'homme
par l'intermédiaire d'un animal infecté
et qualifiés de probables à très
probable ces dernières heures le chef de
la mission en chine et experts de l'eau
m s a de son côté légitimer le travail
de ses confrères oui code d'accès nous
avons eu accès à un grand nombre de
données
mais bien sûr il y à des domaines où
nous avons eu des difficultés à obtenir
les données brutes en chine comme dans
de nombreux autres pays il existe des
restrictions et des lois sur la
protection de la vie privée en
particulier si les données sortent du
pays
personne ne s'attendait à ce que cette
mission apporte une réponse définitive
et que nous arrivions à la fin de la
mission avec un animal quelconque dans
les mains et que nous visions
voici le coupable cela n'a jamais été
l'intention où l'attend
à noter que le rapport n'écarte pas
également l'hypothèse d'une transmission
par de la viande surgelée
ainsi afin d'éviter de futurs
interrogations et une nouvelle crise
sanitaire
mardi le président du conseil européen
et le directeur de oms soutenu par le
président français et la chancelière
allemande ont appelé à élaborer un
traité international sur les pandémies